[Musique]
adepte du vélo la famille neuville
empruntent régulièrement cette piste
cyclable de thise mon vélo pour aller à
l'école ou quand je fais des activités
des fois on fait des sorties des longues
sorties avec papa maman c'est un peu une
philosophie puis donc du coup ils me
suivent aussi à vélo et pas trop choix
il faut il faut aussi une maman donc ils
sont sur le vélo aussi depuis tout petit
depuis qu'ils ont trois ans et demi ou
quatre ans ils ont appris à faire du
vélo et donc on profite de ce moyen de
transport pour circuler en ville
notamment et puis c'est aussi un sport
pour nous d'après le baromètre des
villes cyclables magny les hameaux est
la première commune d'île de france où
il fait bon de pédaler c'est vrai que la
ville se prête bien la circulation il ya
peu de trafic des voies cyclables etc
donc c'est on sent en sécurité aucun
sociale
c'est également à vélo que didier et
marlène vont faire les courses a
romainville habitant de magny les
hameaux ils sont habitués de ce maître
de transports doux on est libre on a pas
de parking que la voiture je vais même
en vélo jusqu'à la gare de 50 à 120 seul
fonds
ça me prend 20 minutes j'ai aussi dit
que le bus un trajet de cinq minutes
pour arriver à destination
tous les deux jours le retraité se
déplace à vélo pour les courses les
rendez-vous administratif ou encore se
rendre à la poste sur le chemin qu'on a
pris là vous venez le week-end c'est
c'est plein plein plein de gens qui vaut
mieux pas prendre la voiture c'est bien
parti mais encore tout à fait surtout
dans la liaison des pistes cyclables en
fait l'interconnexion des pistes
cyclables des travaux encore à faire
dont le maire est conscient maintenant
très clairement la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est les liaisons vers les
autres communes autour et là il faut que
l'ensemble des des collectivités qui ont
ses compétences la fassent aussi leur
travail c'est le cas de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines avec le
plan vélo donc qui vient d'être votée
des axes cyclables notamment avec la
commune de voisins-le-bretonneux
devraient être réalisés les travaux du
plan vélo de saint quentin en yvelines
débuteront 2023 ou 2024 avant les jo
[Musique]